benvenuti a tutti e grazie di
permettermi di condividere con voi
questa mia esperienza in ambito musicale
una delle domande che in genere mi si
pone la seguente come ho scelto di
diventare direttore d'orchestra
fondamentalmente la domanda contiene un
piccolo errore nel senso che io non ho
scelto di diventare direttore
d'orchestra ma semplicemente ho seguito
un percorso musicale molto lungo e
difficile iniziato con lo studio del
pianoforte proseguito con lo studio
della composizione è terminato se così
si può dire ma in realtà allo studio
della musica non termina mai con
l'approccio alla direzione d'orchestra
che cosa mi ha spinto a fare questo una
fortissima curiosità molto semplicemente
il fatto di frequentare sale da concerto
e sentire e la stessa orchestra cambiare
quotidianamente suono con direttori
diversi mi ha sempre incuriosito e mi
domandavo ma perché la stessa orchestra
suona in modo così diverso con direttori
altri e dunque
diciamo che lo studio è stato
soprattutto questo cioè capire il ruolo
del direttore d'orchestra
qual è il suo ruolo in realtà non è così
semplice poterlo definire diciamo
sicuramente che il direttore d'orchestra
è una guida una guida per i musicisti
però è anche colui che trasmette il
proprio sentire attraverso il suo gesto
ma il direttore dr casa si limita a
battere il tempo parlando molto
semplicemente direi proprio di no perché
attraverso la sua gestualità il
direttore dr casa dovrebbe esprimere la
musica c'era uno studio molto
interessante che si faceva e vi
consiglio anche a guardare se avete
tempo vedrete che per esempio c'è una
famosissima lezione di bernstein nella
quale lui dirige ma in realtà non si
muove muove solamente gli occhi quella
era un orchestra veramente ottima e
poteva anche suonare da soli ma
l'esperimento è perfettamente riuscito
perché lui tramite lo sguardo ha
trasmesso la musica e questo era
semplicemente è stato meraviglioso
dunque il ruolo del direttore
d'orchestra è un ruolo di principalmente
di guida ma è anche un ruolo di punto di
riferimento se fate caso il direttore
d'orchestra è posto al centro
dell'orchestra e quindi è un punto di
riferimento per tutti e la posizione
centrale è proprio quella che permette
al direttore di poter in qualche modo
equilibrare lo strumento orchestra
ecco dunque arrivati a quello che io ho
sempre pensato e cioè che l'orchestra in
realtà
uno strumento esattamente come quello
che vedete dietro di me che è un
pianoforte bene l'orchestra è uno
strumento allargato è un pianoforte
immenso e qual è la sua caratteristica
principale quella di essere costituita
da donne e uomini e che cosa cambia ed è
cambia tutto perché perché sia l'uomo
che la donna i professori d'orchestra
suonano secondo seguendo il loro sentire
trasmettono qualche cosa diciamo che
bisognerebbe interpretare questo immenso
strumento come una fonte di energia e di
empatia che ha come scopo finale la
riuscita del concerto rispettando
pedissequamente le indicazioni del
compositore quindi la fedeltà al testo
che per noi è una partitura come quella
che vedete dietro di me è una delle cose
più importanti sia per il direttore che
per i musicisti in che cosa consiste la
direzione dell'orchestra sicuramente non
consiste nel battere il tempo perché il
tempo è un punto di riferimento
naturalmente per tutti ma non si deve
limitare a quello perché vedete che
battere il tempo lo sappiamo fare tutti
quindi ci deve essere qualche altra cosa
in realtà questo qualche altra cosa è
rappresentato dal suono dell'orchestra è
un po come guardare una personale negli
occhi dagli occhi si vede l'anima della
persona si vede e si possono captare i
sentimenti ecco così questo avviene
anche nella direzione d'orchestra dalla
gestualità si intuisce il musicista e se
questo si limita a battere il tempo beh
diciamo che proprio amore
magnifica un'altra delle domande che mi
viene posta abitualmente cosa significa
essere direttore d'orchestra donna la
mia espressione spero che sia stata
chiara per tutti non significa
assolutamente niente perché perché
principalmente il direttore d'orchestra
chiunque esso sia deve essere un
musicista e quindi non si può
assolutamente catalogare il direttore
d'orchestra perché non ha nessun senso
quindi se all'inizio io davo delle
risposte abbastanza secche su questa
domanda questa domanda oggi posso dire
che la cosa per me a interesse zero
veramente 0
no anzi non capisco per quale ragione ci
siamo mi hanno posto e ci siamo ridotti
a pensare che uomo donna non c'entra
assolutamente niente il direttore
d'orchestra del musicista punto basta
poi se è un falco dice oppure un uomo
oppure una donna questo non ho nessuna
importanza quello che ha importanza
riuscire ad essere impatti c a
condividere ea trasmettere e questo in
genere avviene quando di fronte a noi
abbiamo un musicista fatto e finito e
che cosa posso dire di più
io penso che ognuno di noi abbia al suo
interno una voce interiore una una guida
interiore che consigli e permetta di tra
prende
determinati percorsi anche se difficili
non è importante arrivare in poco tempo
o arrivare subito
quello che è importante è mantenere un
equilibrio interno che possa permetterci
di fare quello che sentiamo e di
riuscire a trasmettere il nostro
pensiero e il nostro modo di essere il
nostro modo di sentire in fondo tutto
quello che noi facciamo nelle nostre
vite
il direttore d'orchestra o qualsiasi
altra cosa è bene sono esperimenti che
noi facciamo per migliorare la nostra
vita e per assecondare il nostro modo di
essere e di sentire le cose nei
trasmettiamo qualche cosa
quotidianamente abbiamo tutti un immensa
immensa potenzialità questo è in ognuno
di noi e quindi io suggerisco a tutti di
seguire la propria voce interiore e di
fare in modo che quello che si fa c.so
disse ci gratifichi e ci permetta di
fare qualche cosa che può essere
importante non solo per noi ma anche per
chi ci ascolta
grazie